PETER SZOLOVITS: OK,
so a little over a year
ago, I got a call
from this committee.
NASEM is the National Academy
of Science, Engineering,
and Medicine.
So this is an august body of old
people with lots of gray hair
who have done something
important enough to get elected
to these academies.
And their research arm is called
the National Research Council
and has a bunch of
different committees.
One of them is this Committee
on Science, Technology,
and the Law.
It's a very
interesting committee.
It's chaired by
David Baltimore, who
used to be an MIT professor
until he went and became
president of Caltech.
And he also happens to have
a Nobel Prize in his pocket
and he's a pretty famous guy.
And Judge David
Tatel is a member
of the US Court of Appeals
for the District of Columbia
circuit, so this is probably the
most important circuit court.
It's one level below
the Supreme Court.
And he happens to
sit in the seat
that Ruth Bader
Ginsburg occupied
before she was elevated
to the Supreme Court
from that Court of Appeals,
so this is a pretty big deal.
So these are heavy hitters.
And they convened a meeting to
talk about the set of topics
that I've listed here.
So blockchain and distributed
trust, artificial intelligence
and decision making, which is
obviously the part that I got
invited to talk about,
privacy and informed consent
in an era of big data,
science curricula for law
schools, emerging issues, and
science, technology, and law.
The issue of using litigation
to target scientists who have
opinions that you don't like.
And the more general
issue of how do you
communicate advances in life
sciences to a skeptical public.
So this is dealing with the
sort of anti-science tenor
of the times.
So the group of us that talked
about AI and decision making,
I was a little bit
surprised by the focus
because Hank really is a law
school professor at Stanford
who's done a lot of work
on fairness and prejudice
in health care.
Cherise Burdee is at something
called the Pretrial Justice
Institute, and her
issue is a legal one
which is that there are
now a lot of companies that
have software that predict,
if you get bail while you're
awaiting trial, are you
likely to skip bail or not?
And so this is influential
in the decision
that judges make about
how much bail to impose
and whether to let
you out on bail at all
or to keep you in prison,
awaiting your trial.
Matt Lundgren is a radiology
professor at Stanford
and has done some of
the really cool work
on building convolutional
neural network
models to detect pulmonary
emboli and various other things
in imaging data.
You know the next guy, and
Suresh Venkatasubramanian
is a professor.
He was originally a theorist
at the University of Utah
but has also gotten into
thinking a lot about privacy
and fairness.
And so that that was our panel,
and we each gave a brief talk
and then had a very
interesting discussion.
One of the things that I was
very surprised by is somebody
raised the question of shouldn't
Tatel as a judge on the Circuit
Court of Appeals
hire people like you
guys to be clerks in his court?
So people like you
guys who also happen
to go to law school, of
which there are a number now
of people who are trained
in computational methods
and machine learning but also
have the legal background.
And he said something
very interesting to me.
He said, no, he
wouldn't want people
like that, which
kind of shocked me.
And so we quizzed him
a little bit on why,
and he said, well, because he
views the role of the judge
not to be an expert
but to be a judge.
To be a balancer of arguments
on both sides of an issue.
And he was afraid that
if he had a clerk who
had a strong
technical background,
that person would have strong
technical opinions which
would bias his decision
one way or another.
So this reminded me--
my wife was a lawyer,
and I remember,
when she was in law school, she
would tell me about the classes
that she was taking.
And it became obvious
that studying law
was learning how to win, not
learning how to find the truth.
And there's this
philosophical notion
in the law that says that
the truth will come out
from spirited argument on
two sides of a question,
but your duty as a lawyer is
to argue as hard as you can
for your side of the argument.
And in fact, in law school,
they teach them, like in debate,
that you should be able to
take either side of any case
and be able to make a
cogent argument for it.
And so Tatel sort of
reinforced that notion
in what he said, which I
thought was interesting.
Well, just to talk a little
bit about the justice area
because this is the one
that has gotten the most
public attention, governments
use decision automation
for determining eligibility
for various kinds of services,
evaluating where to deploy
health inspectors and law
enforcement personnel,
defining boundaries
along voting districts.
So all of the gerrymandering
discussion that you hear about
is all about using
computers and actually
machine learning techniques
to try to figure out how to--
your objective function is to
get Republicans or Democrats
elected, depending on who's in
charge of the redistricting.
And then you tailor these
gerrymandered districts
in order to maximize the
probability that you're
going to have the majority in
whatever congressional races
or state legislative races.
So in the law, people are
in favor of these ideas
to the extent that they
inject clarity and precision
into bail, parole, and
sentencing decisions.
Algorithmic technologies
may minimize
harms that are the
products of human judgment.
So we know that people
are in fact prejudiced,
and so there are prejudices
by judges and by juries
that play into the decisions
made in the legal system.
So by formalizing
it, you might win.
However, conversely,
the use of technology
to determine whose liberty
is deprived and on what terms
raises significant
concerns about transparency
and interpretability.
So next week, we're going to
talk some about transparency
and interpretability,
but today's is really
about fairness.
So here is an article from
October of last year--
no, September of last year,
saying that as of October
of this year, if you get
arrested in California,
the decision of whether
you get bail or not
is going to be made by
a computer algorithm,
not by a human being, OK?
So it's not 100%.
There is some discretion on the
part of this county official
who will make a recommendation,
and the judge ultimately
decides, but I suspect
that until there
are some egregious
outcomes from doing this,
it will probably be
quite commonly used.
Now, the critique of
these bail algorithms
is based on a number
of different factors.
One is that the algorithms
reflect a severe racial bias.
So for example, if you are two
identical people but one of you
happens to be white and one
of you happens to be black,
the chances of you
getting bail are
much lower if you're black
than if you're white.
Now, you say, well,
how could that
be given that we're learning
this algorithmically?
Well, it's a complicated
feedback loop
because the algorithm is
learning from historical data,
and if historically, judges have
been less likely to grant bail
to an African-American than
to a Caucasian-American,
then the algorithm will learn
that that's the right thing
to do and will
nicely incorporate
exactly that prejudice.
And then the second
problem, which
I consider to be
really horrendous,
is that in this
particular field,
the algorithms are
developed privately
by private companies
which will not tell you
what their algorithm is.
You can just pay them and
they will tell you the answer,
but they won't tell you
how they compute it.
They won't tell
you what data they
used to train the algorithm.
And so it's really a black box.
And so you have no idea
what's going on in that box
other than by looking
at its decisions.
And so the data
collection system
is flawed in the same way as
the judicial system itself.
So not only are
there algorithms that
decide whether you
get bail or not,
which is after all a
relatively temporary question
until your trial comes
up, although that
may be a long time,
but there are also
algorithms that advise on
things like sentencing.
So they say, how likely is this
patient to be a recidivist?
Somebody who, when
they get out of jail,
they're going to offend again.
And therefore, they deserve
a longer jail sentence
because you want to keep
them off the streets.
Well, so this is a particular
story about a particular person
in Wisconsin, and shockingly,
the state Supreme Court
ruled against this guy,
saying that knowledge
of the algorithm's output
was a sufficient level
of transparency in order
to not violate his rights,
which I think many
people consider to be
kind of an outrageous decision.
I'm sure it'll be appealed
and maybe overturned.
Conversely-- I keep doing on
the one hand and on the other--
algorithms could help
keep people out of jail.
So there's a Wired
article not long ago
that says we can use algorithms
to analyze people's cases
and say, oh, this person
looks like they're really
in need of psychiatric help
rather than in need of jail
time, and so perhaps
we can divert him
from the penal system
into psychiatric care
and keep him out of prison
and get him help and so on.
So that's the
positive side of being
able to use these
kinds of algorithms.
Now, it's not only
in criminality.
There is also a
long discussion--
you can find this
all over the web--
of, for example,
can an algorithm
hire better than a human being.
So if you're a big company
and you have a lot of people
that you're trying to
hire for various jobs,
it's very tempting
to say, hey, I've
made lots and lots
of hiring decisions
and we have some outcome data.
I know which people have
turned out to be good employees
and which people have turned
out to be bad employees,
and therefore, we can base
a first-cut screening method
on learning such an
algorithm and using it
on people who apply for jobs
and say, OK, these are the ones
that we're going to interview
and maybe hire because they
look like they're a better bet.
Now, I have to tell
you a personal story.
When I was an
undergraduate at Caltech,
the Caltech faculty
decided that they
wanted to include student
members of all the faculty
committees.
And so I was lucky
enough that I served
for three years as a member of
the Undergraduate Admissions
Committee at Caltech.
And in those days, Caltech
only took about 220,
230 students a year.
It's a very small school.
And we would actually fly
around the country and interview
about the top half of all the
applicants in the applicant
pool.
So we would talk not
only to the students
but also to their teachers
and their counselors
and see what the
environment was like,
and I think we got a very good
sense of how good a student was
likely to be based on that.
So one day, after the admissions
decisions have been made,
one of the professors, kind
of as a thought experiment,
said here's what we ought to do.
We ought to take the 230
people that we've just
offered admission to and
we should reject them all
and take the next
230 people, and then
see whether the faculty notices.
Because it seemed like a
fairly flat distribution.
Now, of course, I
and others argued
that this would be
unfair and unethical
and would be a waste
of all the time
that we had put into
selecting these people,
so we didn't do that.
But then this guy
went out and he
looked at the data we had
on people's ranking class,
SAT scores, grade point
average, the checkmarks
on their recommendation
letters about whether they
were truly exceptional
or merely outstanding.
And he built a linear
regression model
that predicted the person's
sophomore level grade point
average, which seemed
like a reasonable thing
to try to predict.
And he got a
reasonably good fit,
but what was
disturbing about it is
that in the Caltech
population of students,
it turned out that the beta for
your SAT English performance
was negative.
So if you did particularly
well in English on the SAT,
you were likely to do worse
as a sophomore at Caltech
than if you didn't do as well.
And so we thought
about that a lot,
and of course, we
decided that that
would be really unfair
to penalize somebody
for being good at something,
especially when the school had
this philosophical
orientation that
said we ought to look for
people with broad educations.
So that's just an example.
And more, Science
Friday had a nice show
that you can listen
to about this issue.
So let me ask you, what
do you mean by fairness?
If we're going to define
the concept, what is fair?
What characteristics
would you like
to have an algorithm
have that judges you
for some particular purpose?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's impossible to
pin down sort of, at least
might in my opinion,
one specific definition,
but for the pre-trial
success rate for example,
I think having the error rates
be similar across populations,
across the covariants you
might care about, for example,
fairness, I think
is a good start.
PETER SZOLOVITS: OK, so similar
error rates is definitely
one of the criteria that people
use in talking about fairness.
And you'll see later Irene--
where's Irene?
Right there.
Irene is a master of
that notion of fairness.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When the model says
some sort of observation that
causally shouldn't
be true, and what
I want society to look like
PETER SZOLOVITS:
So I'm not sure how
to capture that
in a short phrase.
Societal goals.
But that's tricky, right?
I mean, suppose that I
would like it to be the case
that the fraction of people
of different ethnicity
who are criminals
should be the same.
That seems like a good
goal for fairness.
How do I achieve that?
I mean, I could pretend
that it's the same,
but it isn't the same
today objectively,
and the data wouldn't
support that.
So that's an issue.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: People who are similar
should be treated similarly,
so engaged sort of
independent of the [INAUDIBLE]
attributes or independent
of your covariate.
PETER SZOLOVITS:
Similar people should
lead to similar treatment.
Yeah, I like that.
AUDIENCE: I didn't make it up.
PETER SZOLOVITS: I know.
It's another of the classic
sort of notions of fairness.
That puts a lot of weight on
the distance function, right?
In what way are
to people similar?
And what characteristics--
you obviously
don't want to use the
sensitive characteristics,
the forbidden characteristics
in order to decide similarity,
because then people will
be dissimilar in ways
that you don't want, but
defining that function
is a challenge.
All right, well, let me show
you a more technical approach
to thinking about this.
So we all know about biases like
selection bias, sampling bias,
reporting bias, et cetera.
These are in the conventional
sense of the term bias.
But I'll show you an example
that I got involved in.
Raj Manrai was a MIT
Harvard HST student,
and he started looking at the
question of the genetics that
was used in order to
determine whether somebody
is at risk for cardiomyopathy,
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy.
That's a big word.
It means that your
heart gets too big
and it becomes sort of flabby
and it stops pumping well,
and eventually, you die of this
disease at a relatively young
age, if, in fact, you have it.
So what happened
is that there was
a study that was done mostly
with European populations
where they discovered that a lot
of people who had this disease
had a certain genetic variant.
And they said, well, that must
be the cause of this disease,
and so it became accepted
wisdom that if you
had that genetic variant, people
would counsel you to not plan
on living a long life.
And this has all
kinds of consequences.
Imagine if you're
thinking about having
a kid when you're
in your early 40s,
and your life expectancy is 55.
Would you want to die
when you have a teenager
that you leave to your spouse?
So this was a consequential
set of decisions
that people have to make.
Now, what happened
is that in the US,
there were tests
of this sort done,
but the problem was that a lot
of African and African-American
populations turned out to have
this genetic variant frequently
without developing
this terrible disease,
but they were all told that they
were going to die, basically.
And it was only after
years when people
noticed that these
people who were supposed
to die genetically weren't
dying that they said,
maybe we misunderstood
something.
And what they misunderstood
was that the population that
was used to develop the
model was a European ancestry
population and not an
African ancestry population.
So you go, well, we must
have learned that lesson.
So this paper was
published in 2016,
and this was one of
the first in this area.
Here's a paper
that was published
three weeks ago in Nature
Scientific Reports that says,
genetic risk factors
identified in populations
of European descent do
not improve the prediction
of osteoporotic fracture
and bone mineral density
in Chinese populations.
So it's the same story.
It's exactly the same story.
Different disease,
the consequence
is probably less
dire because being
told that you're going to break
your bones when you're old
is not as bad as being told
that your heart's going
to stop working when you're in
your 50s, but there we have it.
OK, so technically, where
does bias come from?
Well, I mentioned
the standard sources,
but here is an
interesting analysis.
This comes from
Constantine Aliferis
from a number of
years ago, 2006,
and he says, well, look,
in a perfect world,
if I give you a
data set, there's
an uncountably infinite
number of models
that might possibly explain
the relationships in that data.
I cannot enumerate an
uncountable number of models,
and so what I'm going to do is
choose some family of models
to try to fit, and then I'm
going to use some fitting
technique, like stochastic
gradient descent or something,
that will find maybe a global
optimum, but maybe not.
Maybe it'll find
the local optimum.
And then there is noise.
And so his observation
is that if you
count O as the optimal possible
model over all possible model
families, and if you count
L as the best model that's
learnable by a particular
learning mechanism,
and you call A the actual
model that's learned,
then the bias is
essentially O minus L,
so its limitation
of learning method
related to the target model.
The variance is
like L minus A, it's
the error that's due to the
particular way in which you
learned things, like
sampling and so on,
and you can estimate the
significance of differences
between different models
by just permuting the data,
randomizing, essentially, the
relationships in the data.
And then you get a curve of
performance of those models,
and if yours lies outside
the 95% confidence interval,
then you have a P
equal 0.05 result
that this model is not random.
So that's the typical
way of going about this.
Now, you might say, but isn't
discrimination the very reason
we do machine learning?
Not discrimination
in the legal sense,
but discrimination in
the sense of separating
different populations.
And so you could say,
well, yes, but some basis
for differentiation
are justified
and some basis for
differentiation
are not justified.
So they're either
practically irrelevant,
or we decide for
societal goals that we
want them to be irrelevant
and we're not going
to take them into account.
So one lesson from people who
have studied this for a while
is that discrimination
is domain specific.
So you can't define
a universal notion
of what it means to discriminate
because it's very much tied
to these questions of
what is practically
and morally irrelevant in the
decisions that you're making.
And so it's going to be
different in criminal law
than it is in medicine, than
it is in hiring, than it
is in various other
fields, college admissions,
for example.
And it's
feature-specific as well,
so you have to take
the individual features
into account.
Well, historically,
the government
has tried to regulate
these domains,
and so credit is regulated by
the Equal Credit Opportunity
Act, education by
the Civil Rights
Act and various amendments,
employment by the Civil Rights
Act, housing by the
Fair Housing Act,
public accommodation by
the Civil Rights Act,
more recently, marriage
is regulated originally
by the Defense of
Marriage Act, which
as you might tell
from its title,
was against things like
people being able to marry who
were not a traditional marriage
that they wanted to defend,
but it was struck down
by the Supreme Court
about six years ago as
being discriminatory.
It's interesting, if you look
back to probably before you
guys were born in
1967, until 1967,
it was illegal for an
African-American and a white
to marry each other in Virginia.
It was literally illegal.
If you went to get a marriage
license, you were denied,
and if you got married out
of state and came back,
you could be arrested.
This happened much later.
Trevor Noah, if you know
him from The Daily Show,
wrote a book called
Born a Crime,
I think, and his father
is white Swiss guy
and his mother is a
South African black,
and so it was literally
illegal for him
to exist under the apartheid
laws that they had.
He had to pretend to be--
his mother was his caretaker
rather than his mother
in order to be able
to go out in public,
because otherwise, they
would get arrested.
So this has recently, of
course, also disappeared,
but these are some of
the regulatory issues.
So here are some of the legally
recognized protected classes,
race, color, sex, religion,
national origin, citizenship,
age, pregnancy, familial status,
disability, veteran status,
and more recently,
sexual orientation
in certain jurisdictions,
but not everywhere
around the country.
OK, so given those
examples, there
are two legal doctrines about
discrimination, and one of them
talks about disparate
treatment, which
is sort of related to this one.
And the other talks
about disparate impact
and says, no matter
what the mechanism
is, if the outcome is very
different for different racial
groups typically or
gender groups, then there
is prima facie evidence that
there is something not right,
that there is some
sort of discrimination.
Now, the problem is, how do
you defend yourself against,
for example, a disparate
impact argument?
Well, you say, in order to
be disparate impact that's
illegal, it has to be
unjustified or avoidable.
So for example,
suppose I'm trying
to hire people to climb
50-story buildings that
are under construction, and
you apply, but it turns out
you have a medical
condition which
is that you get
dizzy at times, I
might say, you know what,
I don't want to hire you,
because I don't want
you plopping off
the 50th floor of a building
that's under construction,
and that's probably
a reasonable defense.
If I brought suit
against you and said,
hey, you're
discriminating against me
on the basis of this
medical disability,
a perfectly good defense
is, yeah, it's true,
but it's relevant to the job.
So that's one way
of dealing with it.
Now, how do you demonstrate
disparate impact?
Well, the court has
decided that you
need to be able to show
about a 20% difference
in order to call something
disparate impact.
So the question, of course,
is can we change our hiring
policies or whatever
policies we're using in order
to achieve the same
goals, but with less
of a disparity in the impact.
So that's the challenge.
Now, what's interesting is
that disparate treatment
and disparate impact are really
in conflict with each other.
And you'll find that
this is true in almost
everything in this domain.
So disparate impact is
about distributive justice
and minimizing
equality of outcome.
Disparate treatment is
about procedural fairness
and equality of opportunity,
and those don't always mesh.
In other words, it may well be
that equality of opportunity
still leads to
differences in outcome,
and you can't square
that circle easily.
Well, there's a lot
of discrimination
that keeps persisting.
There's plenty of evidence
in the literature.
And one of the problems
is that, for example,
take an issue like the disparity
between different races
or different ethnicities.
It turns out that we don't
have a nicely balanced
set where the number of
people of European descent
is equal to the number of
people of African-American,
or Hispanic, or
Asian, or whatever
population you choose
descent, and therefore, we
tend to know a lot more
about the majority class
than we know about
these minority classes,
and just that additional data
and that additional knowledge
might mean that we're able to
reduce the error rate simply
because we have a
larger sample size.
OK, so if you want
to formalize this,
this is Moritz Hardt's
part of the tutorial
that I'm stealing
from in this talk.
This was given at KDD about a
year and a half ago, I think.
And Moritz is a
professor at Berkeley
who actually teaches an
entire semester-long course
on fairness in machine learning,
so there's a lot of material
here.
And so he formalizes
the problem this way.
He says, look, a decision
problem, a model, in our terms,
is that we have some X,
which is the set of features
we know about an individual,
and we have some said A, which
is the set of
protected features,
like your race, or your
gender, or your age,
or whatever it is we're trying
to prevent from discriminating
on, and then we have either
a classifier or some score
or predictive function
that's a function of X and A
in either case, and then we have
some Y, which is the outcome
that we're interested
in predicting.
So now you can begin to tease
apart some different notions
of fairness by looking
at the relationships
between these elements.
So there are three criteria
that appear in the literature.
One of them is the
notion of independence
of the scoring function
from sensitive attributes.
So this says that R is
independent from A. Remember,
on the previous slide, I said
that R is a function of--
oops.
R is a function of X and A,
so obviously, that criterion
says that it can't be a
function of A. Null function.
Another notion is
separation of score
and the sensitive attribute
given the outcome.
So this is the one that says
the different groups are
going to be treated similarly.
In other words, if I tell
you the group, the outcome,
the people who did
well at the job
and the people who
did poorly at the job,
then the scoring function is
independent of the protected
attribute.
So that allows a
little more wiggle room
because it says that the
protected attribute can still
predict something
about the outcome,
it's just that you can't use it
in the scoring function given
the category of which
outcome category
that individual belongs to.
And then sufficiency
is the inverse of that.
It says that given
the scoring function,
the outcome is independent
of the protected attribute.
So that says, can we
build a fair scoring
function that separates the
outcome from the protected
attribute?
So here's some detail on those.
If you look at independence--
this is also called by
various other names--
basically, what it says
is that the probability
of a particular
result, R equal 1,
is the same whether
you're in class A or class
B in the protected attribute.
So what does that tell you?
That tells you that the
scoring function has
to be universal over
the entire data set
and has to not distinguish
between people in class
A versus class B. That's a
pretty strong requirement.
And then you can operationalize
the notion of unfairness
either by looking for
an absolute difference
between those probabilities.
If it's greater
than some epsilon,
then you have evidence that this
is not a fair scoring function,
or a ratio test that says,
we look at the ratio,
and if it differs
from 1 significantly,
then you have evidence that this
is an unfair scoring function.
And by the way, this
relates to the 4/5 rule,
because if you make
epsilon 20%, then that's
the same as the 4/5 rule.
Now, the problem-- there are
problems with this notion
of independence.
So it only requires
equal rates of decisions
for hiring, or giving somebody
a liver for transplant,
or whatever topic
you're interested in.
And so what if hiring is based
on a good score in group A,
but random in B?
So for example, what if we
know a lot more information
about group A than
we do about group B,
so we have a better
way of scoring them
than we do of scoring group
B. So you might wind up
with a situation
where you wind up
hiring the same
number of people,
the same ratio of people in
both groups, but in one group,
you've done a good
job of selecting out
the good candidates,
and in the other group,
you've essentially
done it at random.
Well, the outcomes are likely
to be better for a group A
than for group B, which means
that you're developing more
data for the future
that says, we really
ought to be hiring
people in group A
because they have
better outcomes.
So there's this feedback loop.
Or alternatively--
well, of course,
it could be caused
by malice also.
I could just decide as
a hiring manager I'm not
hiring enough
African-Americans so I'm just
going to take some random
sample of African-Americans
and hire them, and then
maybe they'll do badly,
and then I'll have more
data to demonstrate
that this was a bad idea.
So that would be malicious.
There's also a
technical problem,
which is it's possible that
the category, the group
is a perfect predictor
of the outcome, in which
case, of course, they
can't be separated.
They can't be independent
of each other.
Now, how do you
achieve independence?
Well, there are a number
of different techniques.
One of them is--
there's this article
by Zemel about learning
fair representations,
and what it says
is you create a new
world representation, Z,
which is some
combination of X and A,
and you do this by maximizing
the mutual information
between X and Z
and by minimizing
the mutual information
between the A and Z.
So this is an idea
that I've seen
used in machine learning
for robustness rather
than for fairness,
where people say,
the problem is that given
a particular data set,
you can overfit to that data
set, and so one of the ideas
is to do a Gann-like
method where you say,
I want to train my
classifier, let's say,
not only to work well on
getting the right answer,
but also to work as poorly as
possible on identifying which
data set my example came from.
So this is the
same sort of idea.
It's a representation
learning idea.
And then you build
your predictor, R,
based on this representation,
which is perhaps not
perfectly independent of
the protected attribute,
but is as independent
as possible.
And usually, there are knobs
in these learning algorithms,
and depending on how
you turn the knob,
you can affect
whether you're going
to get a better classifier
that's more discriminatory
or a worse classifier
that's less discriminatory.
So you can do that
in pre-processing.
You can do some kind of
incorporating in the loss
function a dependence notion or
an independence notion and say,
we're going to train on
a particular data set,
imposing this notion of
wanting this independence
between A and R as
part of our desiderata.
And so you, again,
are making trade-offs
against other characteristics.
Or you can do post-processing.
So suppose I've built an
optimal R, not worrying
about discrimination, then
I can do another learning
problem that says I'm now going
to build a new F, which takes
R and the protected
attribute into account,
and it's going to minimize the
cost of misclassifications.
And again, there's a knob where
you can say, how much do I
want to emphasize
misclassifications
for the protected
attribute or based
on the protected attribute?
So this was still talking
about independence.
The next notion is separation,
that says given the outcome,
I want to separate A and R.
So that graphical model shows
that the protected attribute
is only related to the scoring
function through the outcome.
So there's nothing else that you
can learn from one to the other
than through the outcome.
So this recognizes that
the protected attribute
may, in fact, be correlated
with the target variable.
An example might be
different success rates
in a drug trial for
different ethnic populations.
There are now some cardiac
drugs where the manufacturer has
determined that
this drug works much
better in certain
subpopulations than it does
in other populations,
and the FDA
has actually approved the
marketing of that drug
to those subpopulations.
So you're not
supposed to market it
to the people for whom
it doesn't work as well,
but you're allowed to
market it specifically
for the people for
whom it does work well.
And if you think about
the personalized medicine
idea, which we've
talked about earlier.
The populations that
we're interested in
becomes smaller and smaller
until it may just be you.
And so there might be a drug
that works for you and not
for anybody else in the
class, but it's exactly
the right drug for you,
and we may get to the point
where that will happen and
where we can build such drugs
and where we can approve their
use in human populations.
Now, the idea here
is that if I have
two populations, blue and green,
and I draw ROC curves for both
of these populations,
they're not
going to be the same, because
the drug will work differently
for those two populations.
But on the other hand, I can
draw them on the same axes,
and I can say, look any place
within this colored region
can be a fair region
in that I'm going
to get the same outcome
for both populations.
So I can't achieve this
outcome for the blue population
or this outcome for
the green population,
but I can achieve any of these
outcomes for both populations
simultaneously.
And so that's one way of
going about satisfying
this requirement when it
is not easily satisfied.
So the advantage of
separation over independence
is that it allows
correlation between R
and Y, even a perfect
predictor, so R
could be a perfect
predictor for Y.
And it gives you incentives
to learn to reduce
the errors in all groups.
So that issue about
randomly choosing
members of the minority
group doesn't work here
because that would suppress
the ROC curve to the point
where there would be no feasible
region that you would like.
So for example, if
it's a coin flip,
then you'd have
the diagonal line
and the only feasible region
would be below that diagonal,
no matter how good the predictor
was for the other class.
So that's a nice characteristic.
And then the final
criterion is sufficiency,
which flips R and Y. So
it says that the regressor
or the predictive variable can
depend on the protected class,
but the protected class is
separated from the outcome.
So for example, the
probability in a binary case
of a true outcome
of Y given that R
is some particular value, R
and A is a particular class,
is the same as the probability
of that same outcome given
the same R value, but
the different class.
So that's related to the
sort of similar people,
similar treatment notion,
qualitative notion, again.
So it requires a parody
of both the positive
and the negative predictive
values across different groups.
So that's another popular
way of looking at this.
So for example, if the scoring
function is a probability,
or the set of all instances
assigned the score R has an R
fraction of positive
instances among them,
then the scoring function is
said to be well-calibrated.
So we've talked about
that before in the class.
If it turns out that R
is not well-calibrated,
you can hack it and you can make
it well-calibrated by putting
it through a logistic function
that will then approximate
the appropriately
calibrated score,
and then you hope that that
calibration will give--
or the degree of
calibration will give you
a good approximation to
this notion of sufficiency.
These guys in the
tutorial also point out
that some data sets actually
lead to good calibration
without even trying very hard.
So for example, this is
the UCI census data set,
and it's a binary prediction
of whether somebody makes
more than $50,000 a year if
you have any income at all
and if you're over 16 years old.
And the feature, there are 14
features, age, type of work,
weight of sample is
some statistical hack
from the Census Bureau,
your education level,
marital status, et
cetera, and what
you see is that the calibration
for males and females
is pretty decent.
It's almost exactly
along the 45 degree line
without having done anything
particularly dramatic
in order to achieve that.
On the other hand, if you
look at the calibration curve
by race for whites
versus blacks,
the whites, not surprisingly,
are reasonably well-calibrated,
and the blacks are not
as well-calibrated.
So you could imagine building
some kind of a transformation
function to improve
that calibration,
and that would get
you separation.
Now, there's a
terrible piece of news,
which is that you can prove,
as they do in this tutorial,
that it's not possible
to jointly achieve
any pair of these conditions.
So you have three
reasonable technical notions
of what fairness
means, and they're
incompatible with each other
except in some trivial cases.
This is not good.
And I'm not going to
have time to go into it,
but there's a very
nice thing from Google
where they illustrate
the results of adopting
one or another of these
notions of fairness
on a synthesized
population of people,
and you can see how
the trade-offs vary
and what the results
are of choosing
different notions of fairness.
So it's a kind of
nice graphical hack.
Again, it'll be on
the slides, and I
urge you to check
that out, but I'm not
going to have time
to go into it.
There is one other problem
that they point out
which is interesting.
So this was a
scenario where you're
trying to hire
computer programmers,
and you don't want to take
gender into account because we
know that women are
underrepresented among computer
people, and so we
would like that not
to be an allowed
attribute in order
to decide to hire someone.
So they say, well,
there are two scenarios.
One of them is that gender,
A, influences whether you're
a programmer or not.
And this is empirically true.
There are fewer women
who are programmers.
It turns out that visiting
Pinterest is slightly more
common among women than men.
Who knew?
And then visiting GitHub is much
more common among programmers
than among non-programmers.
That one's pretty obvious.
So what they say is, if you
want an optimal predictor
of whether somebody's
going to get hired,
it should actually take both
Pinterest visits and GitHub
visits into account, but
because those go back
to gender, which is
an unusable attribute,
they don't like this model.
And so they say, well, we could
use an optimal separated score,
because now, being a programmer
separates your gender
from the scoring function.
And so we can create
a different score
which is not the same
as the optimal score,
but is permitted because it's
no longer dependent on your sex,
on your gender.
Here's another scenario that,
again, starts with gender
and says, look, we know that
there are more men than women
who obtain college degrees
in computer science,
and so there's an
influence there,
and computer scientists
are much more
likely to be programmers than
non-computer science majors.
If you're were a woman--
has anybody visited the Grace
Murray Hopper Conference?
A couple, a few of you.
So this is a really
cool conference.
Grace Murray Hopper invented
the notion bug or the term bug
and was a really famous
computer scientist starting back
in the 1940s when there
were very few of them,
and there is a yearly
conference for women computer
scientists in her honor.
So clearly, the probability that
you visited the Grace Hopper
Conference is dependent
on your gender.
It's also dependent on whether
you're a computer scientist,
because if you're
a historian, you're
not likely to be interested
in going to that conference.
And so in this story,
the optimal score
is going to depend basically
on whether you have a computer
science degree or not,
but the separated score
will depend only on
your gender, which
is kind of funny, because
that's the protected attribute.
And what these guys point out is
that despite the fact that you
have these two scenarios,
it could well turn out
that the numerical data, the
statistics from which you
estimate these models
are absolutely identical.
In other words, the
same fraction of people
are men and women, the
are programmers, they
have the same relationship
to those other factors, and
so from a purely observational
viewpoint, you can't tell
which of these styles of model
is correct or which version of
fairness your data can support.
So that's a problem
because we know
that these different
notions of fairness
are in conflict with each other.
So I wanted to finish by showing
you a couple of examples.
So this was a paper
based on Irene's work.
So Irene, shout if I'm
butchering the discussion.
I got an invitation last year
from the American Medical
Association's Journal of Ethics,
which I didn't know existed,
to write a think piece for
them about fairness in machine
learning, and I decided that
rather than just bloviate,
I wanted to present
some real work,
and Irene had been
doing some real work.
And so Marcia, who was
one of my students,
and I convinced her
to get into this,
and we started looking
at the question of how
these machine learning models
can identify and perhaps reduce
disparities in general
medical and mental health.
Now, why those two areas?
Because we had access
to data in those areas.
So the general medical was
actually not that general.
It's intensive care
data from MIMIC,
and mental health
care is some data
that we had access to from Mass
General and McLean's hospital
here in Boston, which both
have big psychiatric clinics.
So yeah, this is
what I just said.
So the question we were
asking is, is there
bias based on race,
gender, and insurance type?
So we were really interested
in socioeconomic status,
but we didn't have
that in the database,
but the type of insurance you
have correlates pretty well
with whether you're
rich or poor.
If you have Medicaid insurance,
for example, you're poor,
and if you have
private insurance,
the first approximation,
you're rich.
So we did that, and then
we looked at the notes.
So we wanted to see
not the coded data,
but whether the things that
nurses and doctors said
about you as you
were in the hospital
were predictive of readmission,
of 30-day readmission,
of whether you were likely
to come back to the hospital.
So these are some of the topics.
We used LDA, standard
topic modeling framework.
And the topics, as usual,
include some garbage,
but also include a lot of
recognizably useful topics.
So for example, mass,
cancer, metastatic,
clearly associated with
cancer, Afib, atrial, Coumadin,
fibrillation, associated with
heart function, et cetera,
in the ICU domain.
In the psychiatric
domain, you have
things like bipolar, lithium,
manic episode, clearly
associated with bipolar disease,
pain, chronic, milligrams,
the drug quantity, associated
with chronic pain, et cetera.
So these were the
topics that we used.
And so we said,
what happens when
you look at the
different topics,
how often the
different topics arise
in different subpopulations?
And so what we found is that,
for example, white patients
have more topics that
are enriched for anxiety
and chronic pain, whereas black,
Hispanic, and Asian patients
had higher topic
enrichment for psychosis.
It's interesting.
Male patients had more
substance abuse problems.
Female patients had
more general depression
and treatment-resistant
depression.
So if you want to create a
stereotype, men are druggies
and women are depressed,
according to this data.
What about insurance type?
Well, private insurance
patients had higher levels
of anxiety and depression,
and poorer patients
or public insurance
patients had more problems
with substance abuse.
Again, another stereotype
that you could form.
And then you could look at--
that was in the
psychiatric population.
In the ICU population, men still
have substance abuse problems.
Women have more
pulmonary disease.
And we were
speculating on how this
relates to sort of known
data about underdiagnosis
of COPD in women.
By race, Asian patients have
a lot of discussion of cancer,
black patients have
a lot of discussion
of kidney problems,
Hispanics of liver problems,
and whites have
atrial fibrillation.
So again, stereotypes
of what's most common
in these different groups.
And by insurance type,
those with public insurance
often have multiple
chronic conditions.
And so public insurance patients
have atrial fibrillation,
pacemakers, dialysis.
These are indications
of chronic heart disease
and chronic kidney disease.
And private insurance patients
have higher topic enrichment
values for fractures.
So maybe they're richer,
they play more sports
and break their
arms or something.
Lymphoma and aneurysms.
Just reporting the data.
Just the facts.
So these results are
actually consistent with lots
of analysis that have been
done of this kind of data.
Now, what I really
wanted to look at
was this question of, can
we get similar error rates,
or how similar are the
error rates that we get,
and the answer is, not so much.
So for example, if you
look at the ICU data,
we find that the error rates
on a zero-one loss metric
are much lower for men than they
are for women, statistically
significantly lower.
So we're able to more accurately
model male response or male
prediction of 30-day
readmission than we are--
sorry, of ICU mortality for
the ICU than we are for women.
Similarly, we have
much tighter ability
to predict outcomes for
private insurance patients
than for public
insurance patients
with a huge gap
in the confidence
intervals between them.
So this indicates that
there is, in fact,
a racial bias in the
data that we have
and in the models
that we're building.
These are particularly
simple models.
In psychiatry, when you
look at the comparison
for different
ethnic populations,
you see a fair
amount of overlap.
One reason we
speculate is that we
have a lot less data
about psychiatric patients
than we do about ICU patients.
So the models are
not going to give us
as accurate predictions.
But you still see, for example,
a statistically significant
difference between blacks
and whites and other races,
although there's a
lot of overlap here.
Again, between
males and females,
we get fewer errors in
making predictions for males,
but there is not a 95%
confidence separation
between them.
And for private versus
public insurance,
we do see that separation
where for some reason,
in fact, we're able to
make better predictions
for the people on
Medicare than we
are-- or Medicaid than
we are for patients
in private insurance.
So just to wrap that up, this is
not a solution to the problem,
but it's an examination
of the problem.
And this Journal of
Ethics considered
it interesting enough to publish
just a couple of months ago.
The last thing I
want to talk about
is some work of
Willie's, so I'm taking
the risk of speaking
before the people who
actually did the work here
and embarrassing myself.
So this is modeling mistrust
in end-of-life care,
and it's based on
Willie's master's thesis
and on some papers that
came as a result of that.
So here's the interesting data.
If you look at
African-American patients,
and these are patients in the
MIMIC data set, what you find
is that for mechanical
ventilation,
blacks are on
mechanical ventilation
a lot longer than
whites on average,
and there's a pretty
decent separation
at the P equal
0.05 level, so 1/2%
level between those
two populations.
So there's something going
on where black patients are
kept on mechanical ventilation
longer than white patients.
Now, of course, we
don't know exactly why.
We don't know whether
it's because there
is a physiological
difference, or because it
has something to do
with their insurance,
or because God knows.
It could be any of a lot
of different factors,
but that's the case.
The eICU data set
we've mentioned,
it's a larger, but less
detailed data set, also of
intensive care patients, that
was donated to Roger Marks' Lab
by Phillips Corporation.
And there, we see,
again, a separation
of mechanical ventilation
duration roughly
comparable to what we saw
in the MIMIC data set.
So these are consistent
with each other.
On the other hand, if you look
at the use of vasopressors,
blacks versus whites, at
the P equal 0.12 level,
you say, well,
there's a little bit
of evidence, but
not strong enough
to reach any conclusions.
Or in the eICU
data, P equal 0.42
is clearly quite
insignificant, so we're not
making any claims there.
So the question that
Willie was asking,
which I think is a
really good question, is,
could this difference be due
not to physiological differences
or even these sort of
socioeconomic or social
differences, but to a difference
in the degree of trust
between the patient
and their doctors?
It's an interesting idea.
And of course, I wouldn't
be telling you about this
if the answer were no.
And so the approach
that he took was
to look for cases where
there's clearly mistrust.
So there are red flags
if you read the notes.
For example, if a patient
leaves the hospital
against medical advice, that
is a pretty good indication
that they don't trust
the medical system.
If the family-- if the
person dies and the family
refuses to allow them
to do an autopsy,
this is another
indication that maybe they
don't trust the medical system.
So there are these sort of red
letter indicators of mistrust.
For example, patient
refused to sign ICU consent
and expressed
wishes to be do not
resuscitate, do not
intubate, seemingly very
frustrated and mistrusting
of the health care system,
also with a history of
poor medication compliance
and follow-up.
So that's a pretty
clear indication.
And you can build a
relatively simple extraction
or interpretation model that
identifies those clear cases.
This is what I was
saying about autopsies.
So the problem, of course,
is that not every patient
has such an obvious label.
In fact, most of them don't.
And so Willie's idea
was, can we learn a model
from these obvious
examples and then
apply them to the
less obvious examples
in order to get a kind
of a bronze standard
or remote supervision notion
of a larger population that
has a tendency to be mistrustful
according to our model
without having as explicit
a clear case of mistrust,
as in those examples.
And so if you look at chart
events in MIMIC, for example,
you discover that
associated with those cases
of obvious mistrust are
features like the person was
in restraints.
They were literally
locked down to their bed
because the nurses
were afraid they would
get up and do something bad.
Not necessarily
like attack a nurse,
but more like fall out of bed
or go wandering off the floor
or something like that.
If a person is in pain, that
correlated with these mistrust
measures as well.
And conversely, if you saw that
somebody had their hair washed
or that there was a discussion
of their status and comfort,
then they were probably
less likely to be
mistrustful of the system.
And so the approach
that Willie took
was to say, well, let's code
these 620 binary indicators
of trust and build a
logistic regression
model to the labeled
examples and then
apply it to the unlabeled
examples of people for whom
we don't have such
a clear indication,
and this gives us another
population of people who
are likely to be
mistrustful and therefore,
enough people that we can
do further analysis on it.
So if you look at
the mistrust metrics,
you have things like if
the patient is agitated
on some agitation scale, they're
more likely to be mistrustful.
If, conversely,
they're alert, they're
less likely to be mistrustful.
So that means they're in
some better mental shape.
If they're not in
pain, they're less
likely to be
mistrustful, et cetera.
And if the patient
was restrained,
then trustful
patients have no pain,
or they have a spokesperson
who is their health care proxy,
or there is a lot of
family communication,
but conversely, if restraints
had to be reapplied,
or if there are various
other factors, then
they're more likely
to be mistrustful.
So if you look at that
prediction, what you find
is that for both predicting the
use of mechanical ventilation
and vasopressors, the
disparity between a population
of black and white
patients is actually
less significant
than the disparity
between a population of high
trust and low trust patients.
So what this suggests is that
the fundamental feature here
that may be leading
to that difference
is, in fact, not
race, but is something
that correlates with
race because blacks
are more likely
to be distrustful
of the medical
system than whites.
Now, why might that be?
What do you know about history?
I mean, you took the
city training course
that had you read the Belmont
Report talking about things
like the Tuskegee experiment.
I'm sure that leaves a
significant impression
in people's minds about how
the health care system is going
to treat people of their race.
I'm Jewish.
My mother barely lived
through Auschwitz,
and so I understand some
of the strong family
feelings that happened
as a result of some
of these historical events.
And there were medical people
doing experiments on prisoners
in the concentration
camps as well,
so I would expect that
people in my status
might also have similar
issues of mistrust.
Now, it turns out,
you might ask, well,
is mistrust, in fact,
just a proxy for severity?
Are sicker people
simply more mistrustful,
and is what we're seeing
just a reflection of the fact
that they're sicker?
And the answer seems
to be, not so much.
So if you look at these severity
scores like OASIS and SAPS
and look at their correlation
with noncompliance in autopsy,
those are pretty low
correlation values,
so they're not explanatory
of this phenomenon.
And then in the population,
you see that, again, there
is a significant
difference in sentiment
expressed in the notes between
black and white patients.
The autopsy derived
mistrust metrics don't
show a strong relationship, a
strong difference between them,
but the noncompliance
derived mistrust metrics do.
So I'm out of time.
I'll just leave you
with a final word.
There is a lot more work that
needs to be done in this area,
and it's a very rich area
both for technical work
and for trying to understand
what the desiderata are
and how to match them to
the technical capabilities.
There are these
various conferences.
One of the people
active in this area, one
of the pairs of people, Mike
Kearns and Aaron Roth at Penn
are coming out with a book
called The Ethical Algorithm,
which is coming out this fall.
It's a popular pressbook.
I've not read it,
but it looks like it
should be quite interesting.
And then we're starting
to see whole classes
in fairness popping up at
different universities.
University of Pennsylvania has
the science of Data ethics,
and I've mentioned already this
fairness in machine learning
class at Berkeley.
This is, in fact, one of the
topics we've talked about.
I'm on a committee
that is planning
the activities of
the new Schwarzman
College of Computing,
and this notion
of infusing ideas about
fairness and ethics
into the technical curriculum
is one of the things
that we've been discussing.
The college obviously
hasn't started yet,
so we don't have anything
other than this lecture
and a few other things
like that in the works,
but the plan is there to
expand more in this area.